in 2001 it snowed in New Jersey on
December 23rd which was one of the
busiest days of the year
typically December 23rd is the busiest
day of the year in a liquor store and a
woman called us which just started
shipping and her case of behringer White
Zinfandel wasn't delivered the entire
case by the way 15 pack the entire 15
pack case cost $45 we're doing about
$40,000 an hour in the store she calls I
find out about it and we're debating
what to do she needs it for her
Christmas dinner I grabbed the case
throw it in my car and drive to Bergen
County to deliver it it takes me two and
a half hours to complete the whole thing
and the best part was I delivered it all
pumped with myself and she said great
and close the door awesome everybody
especially my dad who was pissed that I
left because all the customers that came
in asking for me or that I could have
sold everybody who's baffled I can't
tell you what the ROI of driving through
the snow in my car to deliver a case of
$45 pink [ __ ] to a woman that looked
like Yoda was but I can tell you this
over the next two to three years that
story became the foundation of how we
treated every single customer it became
our competitive edge but I'm telling you
right now that there are way too many
[ __ ] running businesses today with
this and not enough people running
businesses with this
you